une falaise noir 8 chemin 14 pigeons et
un cheval voilà le décor surprenant de
falaise ce spectacle de la compagnie
baro d'evel se joue ce jeudi 9 décembre
à 20h30 au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une métaphore
d'un monde en déclin on travaille
beaucoup avec les rythmes avec les voix
avec le mouvement il ya deux danois de
langage
là on vient du cirque mais on est plutôt
dans une forme d'écriture contemporaine
avec un mélange de beaucoup de choses
dans cette performance qui mélange
absurde et humour les pigeons et le
cheval sont partie intégrante de la
troupe et du spectacle on retrouve dans
le travail avec des animaux ou même avec
des enfants quelque chose qui nous
nour ali au moment présent et aussi
voilà cette espèce de connexion de la
justesse ce qu'on cherche non en tant
qu'interprète nom de rester juste les
soirs dès que tous les soirs on rejoue
la mémé carte pour refaire le spectacle
que ce soit un moment extraordinaire
cirque danse et théâtre dans un paysage
apocalyptique fallait ce voeu d'être une
oeuvre totale là sur falaise il ya ce
côté on rentre dans un théâtre et on
prend un peu le langage du théâtre pour
le détourner pour en faire autre chose
c'est par spectacle de théâtre messages
laissés pense peut-être dénonce mais ça
ne l'est pas ce que tu es de cirque me
semblait quand même donc c'est vrai que
c'est là où je pense ce
la singularité du travail de voir des
belles et là dessus deux autres
représentations sont prévues vendredi 10
et samedi 11 décembre toujours au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines